Йому 93-ри, але в нього молодіжна зачіска.
Він ходить з прямою спиною і взагалі надзвичайно інтелігентна людина.
Трохи накульгує на прострілену під час Другої світової війни ногу,
але ні від кого не приймає допомогу.
Це Михайло Олександрович Заславський.
Він, можна сказати, двічі народився в Одесі.
Вперше - увеликій єврейській родині, за 16 років до нападу нацистів на СРСР.
Удруге - через три місяці після початку війни.
Ось тут, на місціколишніх порохових складів.
Сюди зігнали усіх євреїв Одеси у жовтні 1941-го,
через тиждень після того, як румунсько-німецькі війська уввійшли в місто.
Коли нас повели із в'язниці, я спершу думав, що, ну, ведуть кудись, імовірно, в одне велике гетто.
Але я не передбачав, що спалять все одно.
Михайло Олександрович досі має чудову пам'ять і детально розповідає,
як відбувалося масове знищення майже двадцяти трьох тисяч євреїв.
За його спогадами в місцевому музеї Голокосту зробили ось цей макет.
Десь тут навіки залишилися його мати,тітка, п'ятирічний братик і три маленькі сестрички.
Їх разом з іншими жінками та дітьми відвели в окремі бараки.
Чоловіків зачинили в інших. Все облили бензином і підпалили.
Михайло Олександрович зміг втекти через дірку, яка виникла, коли впалабалка.
Відкрив кулеметник вогонь. Я чув свист куль,
чув тупіт ніг, зойки, падіння тіл, можливо, передсмертні крики поранених,
можливо, поранених.
Скільки іще людей вибігли, не знаю.
Але я обертався і бачив, як палали бараки, я бачив полум'я над ними.
Михайло Олександрович каже, що до війни був "справжнім одеським хуліганом".
Себто знав всі потаємні кутки міста.
Це його і врятувало, коли довелося ховатися від нацистів у полях під містом,
підвалах та навіть у склепах на кладовищах.
Потім, коли голод загнав його знову в Одесу, румунські нацисти не раз затримували хлопця.
Документів вмене не було, але був природній документ.
Коли я народився, тато не схотів, щоб мені робили обрізання.
І я як був, так і залишився необрізаним євреєм.
А у румун було, в разі чого, знімай штані, показуй паспорт природній.
Це мене і врятовувало. Яне соромлюсь про це говорити.
Що він відчував до окупантів, які вбили його родину, Михайло Олександрович не каже.
Але, щойно визволили Одесу, він записався в Червону Армію.
Пройшов всю війну, повернувся в рідне місто: а там ані рідних, ні будинку.
На місці масового знищення людей звели військове містечко.
Тему одеського Бабиного Яру в радянські часи замовчували.
Відроджувати пам'ять про загиблих почали вже в незалежній Україні у 90-х роках.
На той час Заславський вийшов на пенсію,
але разом з іншими, хто вижив в фашистських концтаборах,
від добився створення музею Голокосту і зведення пам'ятника загиблим.
Мабуть, його ще ніколи так не мили
вперше за 77 років на місці трагедії збираються дипломати Німеччини, Румунії, Ізраїлю і України.
Адже в Європі про одеський Бабин Яр майже нічого невідомо.
Ми прийшли на це трагічне місце, щоб попросити вибачення…
Це слова з листа одеситам канцлерки Німеччини Анґели Меркель - і Михайло Олександрович приймає їх.
Каже, що вибачити можна, але забути - ніколи.
Він і зараз не знаходить відповіді на питання:
звідки у колись мирних жителів Німеччини і Румунії з'явилася така жорстокість.
Яку провину можна було пред'явити моїй сестрі, якщо їй лише рочок,
моїй молодшій сестрі, їй рік минув.
От за що її і інших дітей, за що спалили?
А як піднялася рука таких малюків і трохи доросліших
разом з матерями зачиняти в цих бараках і спалювати.
Це навіть не варварство, а я навіть не знаю що...
Михайло Олександрович готовий скільки завгодно розповідати про ті трагічні події в Одесі -
щоб якомога більше людей про це дізналися.
Велике спасибі за те, що знайшли час і можливість прийти. Дякую за те, що послухали.
Здоров'я починає підводити Михайла Олександровича.
Та все ж він сподівається на власні очі побачити,
як сюди, на місце трагедії, почнуть приходити гіди з туристами.
А про ті події з'явиться книга або кінофільм.
Представники Німеччини готові підтримати Заславського,
щоб зберегти пам'ять про тисячі людей,
на місці спалення яких нині висічіють елітні багатоповерхівки.